Everyone seems to know everything about everything
these days.
I don't mean people seem to just have an opinion
on any given topic which is great, and that's
what free speech is all about.
Instead, what I'm talking about here is the
constant and endless stream of people pretending
that they know exactly how to run the world
if only everyone would listen to them.
Iran nuclear deal?
The anime Twitter fox knows all about enriched
uranium.
How to destroy ISIS?
You're unemployed cousin knows exactly demolish
them!
The best way to administer healthcare?
Your mom's friend on Facebook who can't figure
out how to unlock her iPad has figured it
out how to make single payer work!
This constant constant expression of fake
knowledge is partly a function of social media,
which rewards us for quick hits and maximum
snark, but it is also a function of something
that's been built into us since our beginning...the
human ego.
Ego is constantly rewarded in this crazy world
we live in.
Do you think the rise of Trump might have
a little something to do with ego?
Clearly Trump understands the way we all connect
to a powerful personality and he uses that
power in every interaction that he has be
it via a speech, a meeting or on Twitter.
But beneath this connection seems to be the
fragile ego of a child who must lash out any
time they hear anything not to their liking.
By the way, I don't think a politician using
the persuasive power of personality something
new as far as the president is concerned.
While Trump is a particularly interesting
case of ego in the White House, let's not
pretend Barack Obama with his promises of
hope and change didn't have one as well.
Or Bill Clinton, who was a master at making
every person in the room feel like they were
the only person he cared about.
While there isn't a direct comparison to of
the charm of Obama and Clinton to the alpha
male tactics of Trump, there is an interesting
through line to what types of people we respond
to.
Interestingly, I'm not sure you could say
that George W. Bush falls into this strong
ego bucket.
Like W or not, there was a humbleness, perhaps
born of insecurity, he had and I think the
others lacked.
Of course W had his own set of problems, but
that's a whole other story.
Now let me back up for a second.
I don't think having an ego is bad-- after
all, each of us has an ego in some way.
By definition, an ego is a person's sense
of self-esteem or self importance.
Of course having a sense of self-esteem and
self importance is good, overall.
Nobody wants to be walking around feeling
worthless and irrelevant.
Feeling worthless isn't healthy for you, and
it's not great for anyone around you, either.
Of course on the other hand, an inflated sense
importance can be dangerous.
Here's where I have to be careful --many of
the brightest minds in arts, sports, politics,
science and virtually every other field have
an inflated sense of self importance, and
this trait is partly what helps them in achieving
greatness.
I think it's fair to say the astronomical
success of Steve Jobs, Michael Jordan and
Beyonce all have a little something to do
with their sense of self importance, driven
by an inflated self esteem.
The endless dedication, hard work and sacrifice
it takes to be a leader in your field often
can be born out of ego.
To pretend this doesn't exist in people we
love and admire, or that it is exclusively
a bad thing, would be to deny something very
human.
And by the way, I won't be presumptuous enough
to think I don't have an ego myself, after
all, I talk on camera for a living.
The ego we all have, to various degrees, is
partly what's causing such disconnect in our
conversations right now.
We judge too quickly, we jump to conclusions
without evidence and we condemn too fast,
all somehow guised as a way of showing how
smart and how correct we are.
I for one have no problem telling you I don't
have all the answers.
I think you guys know most of my opinions
on the big issues and I love sharing them
with you as my opinions change, evolve, or
strengthen.
But on major, complex issues, like the Iran
deal, or Healthcare, or abortion, or gun control,
I don't pretend to have every answer.
Do you think most of the so called experts
who pontificate on everything actually read
the full text of the Iran deal ? How many
experts or even congressmen actually fully
read Obama care or the Republican replacement?
I'm guessing some did, but a very small minority.
Instead of doing the rigorous work to figure
out what is best, they instead pretend to
know everything, and make us feel as if only
if we would listen to them, we'd have a perfect
society.
It's silly, lazy thinking.
Of course our mainstream news, which doles
out supposed important conversations in 5
minute clips with 8 different guests all talking
over each other at once really isn't helping
the situation.
And on the broader issues like abortion or
gun control, pretending that you know exactly
how the law should be so that everything will
work out just right for society is equally
as nonsensical.
We live in a pluralistic society and the human
factor, the simple fact that we're all individuals,
is proof that nothing will ever be perfect
for all of us.
What we can do is limit the amount of control
we have over each other, while at the same
time respecting others beliefs and the same
right to property and happiness that we want
others to afford to us.
Most of us want sensible answers and being
real with ourselves is the only way we're
gonna get there.
Saying "I don't know" or "I haven't decided"
or "I need more information" shouldn't be
seen as a weakness, it should be seen as an
asset.
Oh, and by the way, of course I'm guilty of
sometimes jumping too conclusions and judging
before I have the proper information.
And again, I have an ego too, one by the way
which you often help me keep in check...But
I will never pretend I have all the answers,
and if I ever do I have no doubt you fine
folks will let me know in the comments right
down below...